i have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime you want
this is an anti-vaccine caller
who's been calling in for a while she
took up a full three minutes today on
the voicemail that's the max it cuts you
off let's listen to a little bit of it
uh it's some pretty pretty full-on stuff
yeah remember when you got to go to some
clinic somewhere and get your
vaccine ahead of the
crowd there yeah that didn't happen
wow talk about being a [ __ ]
listen
guess what that wears off you gotta go
get another one
like that's not a setup
billions are being made and that's why
they're turning away any other possible
solutions
there's like
that's there's no evidence of that i
mean billions are being made but there's
no evidence of the second part
see you got a bad cold right but you got
by the way it sounds like roseanne barr
but i know roseanne's politics aren't
like this
you got cough syrup you got your basic
at the drugstore right yeah you don't
have to go to the emergency for that
but they've taken away
something that someone could take
before they got in a position where they
needed to go to an emergency room
and yes
steroids are
a really bad drug
unless they're helping you not die
yeah so steroids haven't been taken away
i mean if it it's it's pretty typical
that
for certain covate you give
dexamethasone or maybe they're using
prednisone
and we know about the effect of steroids
i mean it does it does suppress the
immune system to a degree but maybe
allows healing to take place there's
nothing new there's nothing
controversial there they're helping you
not die
god damn how much do you how much is
pfizer paying you for this [ __ ]
you know what's funny about that
um it's actually the anti-vaxx people
that are being paid when the science is
clear
you don't need to pay anyone to report
on the science and this is a very good
point that was made to me in the email
which is david you know when people
write to you and they say or they leave
a voicemail saying you're getting paid
to promote the vaccine
first of all there's no evidence
anybody's being paid to promote the
vaccine
but you don't really need to pay people
to just look at science and report it
whereas we know of prominent
anti-vaxxers actually being paid
influencers really how much are you you
must be raking in the bucks man to be
going attacking ivermectin
a human drug that's used worldwide for
years and it's on the world health
organization list of essential drugs for
humans well as we talked about before
used for roundworm uh parasites so this
this is uh this is just a peek into the
voicemail we've got a great bonus show
for you today in the midst of all this
texas republican governor greg abbott is
banning all vaccine mandates
france will ban plastic packaging for
most fruits and vegetables that seems
logical right and we'll talk about
samsung's continued struggles with their
foldable mobile phones what's going on
there
trouble
in tech paradise all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com and you will
get instant access